Nobel prize winning Economist Paul
Krugman made an ominous prediction
recently saying AI like chat GPT won't
change the world anytime soon the reason
this is terrifying is that he's the same
guy who also predicted in the 1990s that
the internet was about as game changing
as a fax machine when it comes to
programming I've already seen enough the
need to memorize syntax for programming
is done the future is deterministic AI
pseudocode and the future is now uh
ladies and gentlemen if you will look
right here today's video is yet another
react.js tutorial just one of Millions
on the internet but it's no ordinary
tutorial it's the first tutorial to
leverage the full power of AI to write
code like a 10x developer even if you've
never written a single line of code in
your life what's crazy though is that
this tutorial can be applied to any
language or framework once you know some
basic programming principles and how to
prompt like a pro you can build almost
anything in your imagination but it's
not as simple as just asking chatgpt to
build you a react app you will need some
domain knowledge and understand how to
execute and validate the code that the
AI spits out let's go ahead and get
started with your AI printing
masterclass I'm assuming you know
nothing about react other than it's a
library for building uis I could sit
here and teach you about react and ask
you to buy my 500 react course but the
truth is that gpt4 can teach you better
than I can I hate to admit it but it's
true if you want to learn something you
know absolutely nothing about go ahead
and prompt it to explain it like you're
five in this case it'll explain how
react.js components are like Lego bricks
but for building websites which is the
perfect metaphor from there I ask it for
the most important Concepts that I
should know it then explains components
State and props and hooks if there's
anything you don't understand here you
can then prompt it to explain that one
thing in more detail or explain that to
you like your five one problem though is
that llms tend to hallucinate AKA makes
stuff up so as of today it's not really
a replacement for the react.js
documentation which is excellent by the
way however chat EBT has a browser
plugin that's on a waitlist right now
which will eventually solve that
hallucination problem so the react.js
docs are like the Bible and chatgpt is
like a priest who makes all the money
but sometimes invents his own ideas now
once you have a general idea about the
language or framework that you're trying
to build with the next step is to set up
a project that allows you to inject AI
code in a safe and effective way there's
an old programming proverb that says if
code is not tested it doesn't work and
that's especially true when working with
an AI that acts like it's tripping bowls
I'm freaking out man as someone who's
done a lot of react development I'm just
going to do it the old-fashioned way and
set the project up the way I want it
manually but doing things like this is
very 2022. like yesterday on Twitter I
saw this guy set up and build a project
entirely from voice commands and then
deploy it to versel
which means it did in fact deploy dude
it did it it nailed the background no
way I'm using vs code for Microsoft as
my editor it's not available today but
GitHub copilot X is coming a plug-in for
vs code that brings chat EPT directly
into your editor make sure you're
subscribed for the latest updates on
that tool the only other tool you'll
need is chat EPT ideally with gpt4 which
is currently paid but 3.5 will work as
well here I have vs code open to my
terminal with node.js installed in the
future we'll have tools like GitHub
copilot CLI that can find and explain
commands for us but for now I'm just
going to initialize a new react project
with VJs we'll go ahead and use
typescript because I have some
typescript tricks to show you and then
once inside that project we'll go ahead
and install another tool called
playwright for end-to-end testing in the
browser When developing an app testing
is technically not required but it's
extremely important when working with AI
because we need to validate that it does
what it's supposed to the good news
though is that AI can write its own test
as we'll see shortly now the main
component in the source directory is in
the app.tsx file let's go ahead and
prompt chatgpt to replace it with a more
basic hello world gpt4 is kind of slow
and can often be overly verbose so one
thing you can do is just say code only
to shorten the response that looks
pretty good let's copy and paste it into
our project now go to the terminal and
run npm run Dev and you should get this
hello world component but that's a
little too simple let's go back to chat
EPT and now have it modify this code
with a button that will toggle the
visibility of the hello world text when
doing that it explains how we'll need to
use react state to manage the visibility
paste the updated code into your project
save it and now you have a working
interactive react app that's pretty cool
but we want to make sure that the AI
doesn't accidentally break this code in
the future so let's ask it to write a
test with playwright once again copy the
code then go into the test directory and
create a new file called app.test.ts
here's a pro tip as a printing engineer
you can use control V on your keyboard
instead of doing right click paste to
maximize your speed now from there we
need to go into the package Json file
and set up a testing script if you
already have copilot installed you can
just type test and it should
automatically detect playwright and
create the script for you which is just
playwright test from there we can open
the terminal run npm run test and
playwright will test this code on
multiple browsers in parallel as you can
see it fails because we don't have the
right localhost Port set up so let's go
ahead and modify that in our testing
code and run it again this time it
passes in the future GitHub copilot will
know the full context of your project
and won't make silly mistakes like these
this is cool and all but what you'll
find is your app grows more and more
complex it becomes harder and harder to
prompt the AI effectively it's
non-deterministic which means you can
get different results from the same
prompt you never know what you're going
to get and that's complete Madness for a
programmer but now here's where things
get really mind-blowing and will give
you a glimpse into the future of
programming at this point you have the
general idea of how react works but you
may not know JavaScript very well or
haven't memorized all the little quirks
in the framework or maybe you're a react
expert and just don't want to go through
the tedious process of writing perfectly
structured code so what we can do next
is have chat GPT come up with a
pseudocode language for react what this
will do is allow us to agree on some
general guidelines to represent the
structure of a react component as you
can see here it looks kind of like yaml
and allows us to Define State and then
the rendering function or jsx and if we
don't like the way it looks we can tell
it to come up with a different idea like
maybe make it look more like python
actually no let's make it look like a
cooking recipe which is surprisingly a
very intuitive way to represent a react
component and as an added benefit you
could write this in any human language
and have it translate your pseudocode
back to English but from a practical
standpoint I think you want something
that kind of looks like yaml overall
it's way more concise and doesn't
require us to use precise syntax but at
the same time it will give us relatively
consistent results and we can make it
even better by including relevant
documentation or a style guide to force
it to write code in a style that fits
our project because gpt4 can now handle
up to 25 000 tokens the end result is
your own custom AI pseudocode language
as you can see here I wrote out a
relatively complex component in this
language and it generates perfect react
code as a result but most importantly it
generates the same code every time most
of the time maybe eighty percent of the
time this is pretty mind-blowing because
now any developer can have their own
custom tailored pseudocode language that
can transpile into complex code in
virtually any language without
understanding the underlying syntax in a
previous video I predicted that someday
there will be a universal AI language
but maybe I was wrong maybe every
developer gets to build their own AI
language custom tailored to optimize
their own productivity sounds like chaos
on a team but AI can also translate your
pseudo code into my pseudocode and my
pseudocode into your pseudocode in fact
one thing we could do right now is take
the generated react code and convert it
into a superior framework like svelte or
solid there's a million different
JavaScript Frameworks out there but now
we can use them without learning them in
fact we could use our pseudocode to
build the same app in multiple
Frameworks at the same time then and
Benchmark their performance and just
choose whichever one performs the best
that's more of a futuristic idea but
currently the main value of pseudocode
is just getting things done faster
without allowing the AI to become too
magical like in this example you can see
we're making an API call but currently
we don't have any kind of interface for
the response generally speaking gpt4
will provide better results when you
have statically typed code like
typescript or even just type hints in a
language like python in this case I have
a Json object and what I'll do is paste
that into chat GPT to turn it into a
typescript interface it's able to detect
the two different entities of TV shows
and actors and now we can use it in our
code now that chatgpt has this interface
we can also tell it to generate any kind
of helper functions we'll need like if
we wanted to map this object to all the
actor names that's a pretty handy trick
right now but once again in the future
it won't be necessary tools like copilot
will be able to introspect any API to
provide you with automatic and type
safety without any effort on your part
now the final thing we need to do as a
print engineer is document our code we
simply take the code we've already
generated until chatgpt to document it
congratulations you're now a 10x react
proofed engineer the starting salary is
about 335k this productivity boost is
both exciting and scary Goldman Sachs
just released a report saying that 300
million jobs could be affected by AI in
the near future but there's no reason to
be afraid software systems in real life
are complex beyond belief and not even
state-of-the-artai will want to touch
that code I do believe that AI will make
writing code significantly easier but
building complex software that powers
the world will still be done by humans
in the foreseeable future and my goal
with this channel is to teach you how to
do exactly that thanks for watching and
I will see you in the next one